there's little to do but wait to leave
they may have paid much and risked
drowning to get here but no one not the
migrants the UN not the Italian
government nor the population of this
small island wants them to stay on
lampedusa
[Music]
Claudine is from Cameroon and across
from Libya with her two children earlier
this week since then they've been
sleeping in the open
at the moment I just hope this situation
improves because it's not easy
we've been here since the 12th of
September
therefore we want to leave wherever that
might be we must go
they've had no hope of getting a bed in
lamp producers Migrant Center it was
built for 400 people 8 500 arrived this
week that's more than the Island's
entire local population
from The Gambia spends much of his time
looking for food
so you cannot fit everybody even to have
when you go to the land where they used
to give food sometimes a big deal you
know it's not easy at all so some of us
to have it is a big problem so that's
why we used to go
inside the town
ships have been taking hundreds to
Sicily to reduce the pressure but
political tension has been building
there have been arguments about migrants
between lamp produce as residents
and Italy's right-wing prime minister
wants Ursula vondoline to come see
things for herself
I have written to the president of the
European commission to ask her to come
with me to lampadusa to personally
realized the gravity of the situation we
face and to immediately accelerate the
implementation of the agreement with
Tunisia by transferring the agreed
resources
it's a call Wonderland has heeded which
is expected Inland producer on Sunday
Europe's migration crisis continues and
countries like Italy still feel they're
not getting the help they need Glory
challenge Al Jazeera
make sure to subscribe to our channel to
get the latest news from Al Jazeera